heute geht es um einen teddy trendy
thema das bestimmt ganz viele von euch
schon auf ihrer youtube startseite haben
auf klopfen sehen nämlich um regierung
oder luise nachwachsen lassen bestimmt
kennt ihr diese videos wo man zum
beispiel die wurzel vom ja auch aufhebt
oder so wie es unsere stück in wasser
stellt und dann wächst das wieder nach
da gibt es ja ganz viele tolle tricks
wie man das machen kann aber wie ich
finde auch einige sachen von denen ich
mir nicht vorstellen kann dass sie
wirklich funktionieren wir werden uns
heute mal zusammen 1 in ihren videos
anschauen und dann werde ich meine
einschätzung abgeben ob ich denke dass
es funktionieren könnte dann werden wir
das ganze bei uns ausprobieren und
schauen welche häckseln wirklich klappen
und welche man sich sparen kann okay es
geht los mit einer paprika da werden die
samen heraus gemacht und da kommt der
erde rein und dann wird das ganze in
einen topf gepflanzt und dann wachsen
schnell raus
das sieht mir aber nicht so aus als ob
das paprika plätzchen sind ich würde
eher sagen dass das gurkenpflanzen sind
das also auf jeden fall schonmal gefaked
jeder der schonmal paprika vorgezogen
hatte
keine paprika pflanzen sind was mir
daran ein bisschen sorge bereiten würde
wenn wir das jetzt bei uns hier
ausprobieren ist dass da ja sehr viel
organisches material in den boden
eingegraben wird und ich mir vorstellen
kann dass die paprika sehr schnell fault
und das ist den pflanzen nicht unbedingt
gut tut wenn sie gleich direkt in so
viel organisches material rein wurzeln
dass er noch nicht ganz ersetzt ist wenn
die pflanzen auf gehen aber wir
probieren das aus und gucken was dabei
rauskommt
[Musik]
gegen
das hier ist ein maiskolben ein zucker
maiskolben hat jetzt einige sachen die
ich dazu sagen möchte er sieht nur so
aus als ob der zucker mais gekocht wäre
also das ist so wie ich das einschätzen
kein hoher zucker meist dadurch würden
die samen einfach schon sterben also da
würde dann auch nichts mehr auswachsen
können was man aber auch wissen muss
wenn man samen von mais ernten möchte
und wieder aussehen möchte ist dass die
an der pflanze ausreifen müssen das
heißt man kann den mais nicht ernten
wenn er ganz weich ist und
ja irgendwie noch saftig innen sondern
man muss warten bis die körner hart
geworden sind damit die überhaupt keimen
können also das ist auf jeden fall auch
gefragt und würde ich so nicht zu hause
nachmachen aber wenn wir eins
ausprobieren und gucken was passiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt kommt da eine flasche
wir werden aufpassen dass wir uns dabei
nicht das bügeleisen ruinieren wenn wir
das nachmachen
dann kam der knoblauch rhein und der
wächst und dann kann man ihn rausnehmen
und um pflanzen das kann man so machen
aber ist es absolut unnötig also es
würde auf jeden fall funktionieren
schätze ich so ein aber man kann die
zehn auch einfach ohne dass man sie in
wasser stellt pflanzen und sich diesen
schritt auf jeden fall sparen also das
wäre meiner meinung nach ein nötiger
schritt aber wir gucken mal was passiert
wenn wir das nachmachen
[Musik]
sie hatten keine kleine flasche für den
versuch deswegen mussten wir eine große
nehmen und deswegen ist auch so viel
schief gegangen aber im prinzip steht
der knoblauch jetzt im wasser und wir
werden sehen was passiert also bleibt
bis zum ende dran dann erfahrt ihr
welche hacks funktionieren und welche
eher nicht
jetzt wird eine walnuss aufgeknackt und
eingewickelt in ein feuchtes tuch und
dann kommt da ein spross raus ich kann
mir vorstellen dass es funktioniert
dieser sportart nach soja sprosse aus
vielleicht ich bin sehr gespannt dem ob
da was rauskommt bei uns und wie der
spross dann aussieht also ob das
wirklich ein weihnachtspost sein könnte
die werden ja dann wird der eingegraben
okay weil es dauert es ewig wenn man
außen - einen ganzen baum ziehen will
der dann auch irgendwann früchte tragen
soll deswegen ist es besser sich
pflanzen zu kaufen oder die selbst zu
veredeln weil es einfach vom zeitlichen
her gar nicht so viel sinn ergeben würde
die einfach aus einem samen zu ziehen
aber man kann es machen
das ist mir der walnuss ist irgendwie
ein bisschen schwierig ich habe jetzt so
viele weine versucht obenauf zu machen
aber irgendwie gehen die alle kaputt und
das obwohl ich so fleißige helfer habe
war die vielleicht ein bisschen
übereifrig
aber ich glaube im grunde geht es
einfach nur darum dass der die schale so
ein bisschen offen ist damit der spross
besser raus kommen kann und das habe ich
jetzt bei der weihnachts geschafft also
wir probieren es mal so aus weil so ne
ganz zerbrochen derweil das will ich da
jetzt nicht für nehme
[Musik]
jetzt kommt er auch und ich glaube da
haben wir endlich einen hack der
wirklich funktioniert der wird unten
abgeschnitten also der untere teil die
wurzeln wird in wasser gestellt und dann
wächst da der rauch raus und ich freue
mich schon das mal auszuprobieren ich
mache das immer im bett wir haben am
großen garten das heißt wir müssen so
was nicht auf der fensterbank machen
normalerweise weil wir einfach unser
gemüse aus dem garten kämpfen aber im
beet funktioniert das super also das
müsst ihr immer machen wenn ihr jetzt im
winter eurem lernte dass ihr den einfach
abschneidet so ungefähr vier zentimeter
über dem boden weil dann könnt ihr den
immer wieder neu bewerten weil er immer
wieder nachwächst und ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher dass das im glas
funktioniert kohlheck
[Musik]
genauso schön aus weg ok jetzt wird
kamillentee genommen
und gesagt da würde ich sagen fifty
fifty ob das klappt oder nicht ich kann
es noch nicht so ganz genau einschätzen
aber ich bin sehr gespannt wenn ich mir
vorstellen kann dass die samen in den
blüten noch nicht ganz ausgereift sind
aber vielleicht hat man ja entnehmen
kann so ein paar briten die schon ein
bisschen länger an der pflanze waren so
dass sich das schon sagen entwickeln
konnten mannschaft und ich bin gespannt
ob das klappt
[Musik]
nur kleine stück sinken können gegen
jetzt wird eine wassermelone genommene
ob das peinlich im november wassermelone
kaufen zu gehen oder das ist auf jeden
fall schon möglich dass man sagen aus
einer frucht nimmt und die sieht und
dann kommen da neue pflanzen raus das
kann man auf jeden fall so machen ist
jetzt finde ich nicht so ein krasser
weise funktioniert geht man halt aber
worauf man achten sollte wenn man jetzt
eine wassermelone im laden kauft ist
dass die allermeisten wassermelonen die
man da bekommt hybridsorten sind das
heißt dass die nachkommen dieser
wassermelonen nicht unbedingt
einheitlich genauso sind wie die melone
die man im laden gekauft hat sondern
sehr sehr unterschiedlich sein können es
liegt an der art wie die gezüchtet
werden wir haben zwei pflanzen die
giganten mit dem ganze in zuchtbetrieben
wurde die ganz lange in ihrer familie
und historisch und keine frische den arm
bekommen haben und dann kreuzt man zwei
solcher pflanzen wie sehr schlecht ich
sind und die sehr unter der in sucht
leiden miteinander und dann gibt es so
ein krawall effekt so dass die pflanzen
die dabei rauskommen richtig guten
ertrag haben das ist die wassermelone
die so entstanden die wir im laden
kaufen wird zumindest die allermeisten
nicht alle leute bauen hybridsorten an
aber es ist schon sehr verbreitet weil
man dadurch eben einen sehr großen
ertrag bekommt und dann ist die nächste
generation darunter aber er wieder so
wie die urgroßeltern es ist die
generation die sehr schwach war durch
die dieser effekt erst zustande kommen
konnte deswegen kann man das glück haben
aber man kann auch pech haben man kann
es nie so richtig einschätzen wenn man
hybridsorten weiter vermehrt was dann
dabei rumkommt aber ihr könnt es gerne
ausprobieren ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass da was raus wächst wie man
ausgereifte kerne aus nachbars nimmt die
erde
so ein
[Musik]
erdbeer müssen wir auch kaufen das wird
auch nicht kriegen wir überhaupt welche
okay
die werden ja er hat werden vermehrt man
normalerweise über die ableger die
bilden ja so kleine rampen und da wächst
eine neue kleine pflanze dran so kann
man erdbeeren sehr gut vermehren bei
monats erdbeeren die zum beispiel keine
ableger bilden da verliert man die auch
oft über die samen das ist aber gar
nicht so einfach ich habe das noch nie
ausprobiert also ich bin sehr gespannt
wie das funktioniert aber ich habe von
meinem kurs teilnehmern schon oft gehört
dass sie wirklich probleme hatten air
dance und kaum zu bringen wenn sie das
schon mal ausprobiert haben also mal
gucken ob bei uns was rauskommt wenn man
er denn vermehren möchte also normale
erdbeeren die ranken beten ist das eine
sehr viel einfachere und schnellere
möglichkeit aber ich bin sehr gespannt
auf diese herausforderungen und mal
gucken ob da er beim bei uns rum kommen
wenn wir das jetzt gleich nach machen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die möhre ich glaube das
funktioniert auch das obere ende der
röhre wird also im wasser gegeben und
dann wächst da das meer und grün weiter
werden einen neuen grünen gerne mag dann
ist das glaube ich eine ganz tolle
möglichkeit um sich auf der fensterbank
gemüse zu ziehen allerdings weiß ich
schon immer gar nicht mehr so ganz genau
was wir mit dem höheren grün machen
sollen ihr könnt ihr mal in die
kommentare schreiben wenn die da ideen
habt also haben schon mal pesto gemacht
gegeben dass immer den kennen ihn nicht
wann ist der nachbarn aber ich weiß dass
man da leckere sachen draus machen kann
also wenn ihr ideen habt schreibt das
gerne mal unten rein ich denke dass es
funktionieren wird problem wird es
gleich mal aus ich bin gespannt ein
bisschen was kann man immerhin auch im
garten
[Musik]
jetzt kommt eine tomate und ich hoffe
ich das vielleicht auch wenn diese fängt
mit den aufgeschnittenen scheiben
und die wird in die erde gelegt da ist
wieder so ein bisschen wie bei der
paprika ich finde es ein bisschen zu
viel organisches material um das einfach
so in die erde zu legen und man sollte
darauf achten dass man keine breed sorte
verwendet damit man weiß was dann dabei
herumkommt ja ansonsten denke ich dass
es schon funktioniert ich würde lieber
also vom gärtner instinkt würde ich
lieber die samen aus der tomate raus
kratzen und die dann in die erde legen
um zumindest dieses ganze fleisch aus
drum herum ist nicht drin zu haben aber
ich denke dass es funktionieren wird und
das ist kein problem sind wir zu tomaten
zu ziehen
[Musik]
jetzt werden hier verwelkte blumen
genommen und in die erde gesteckt das
können wir auch mal ausprobieren ich
denke mit manchen blumen könnte es
klappen mit manchen nicht aber ich bin
jetzt auch keine blumen expertin also
mal schauen wir haben eine rose erhöht
werden bis jetzt mal mitte ausprobieren
ob das so klappt oder nicht ich weiß
auch gar nicht was das für eine blume
ist in dem video also wie gesagt ich hab
mehr ahnung von gemüse aber das problem
wir jetzt auch noch mal aus und stecken
mal eine blume in die erde und schauen
was passiert wären jetzt nur eine schöne
rose
[Musik]
es ist jetzt über drei wochen her dass
wir unsere experimente angesetzt haben
die stehen hier an der fensterbank
wurden in der zwischenzeit natürlich von
uns beflügelt gegossen und gepflegt und
einige sachen haben sehr sehr gut
funktioniert und andere überhaupt nicht
und jetzt werden wir die einzelnen
projekte mal durchgehen und schauen
welche sachen geklappt haben und welche
man sich eigentlich ihr schenken kann
fangen wir an mit dem ersten experiment
mit der paprika da ist tatsächlich etwas
raus gewachsen
die paprika fängt allerdings auch schon
ziemlich widerlich an zu schimmeln da
müsste es noch weiter beobachten und
schauen wie sich die pflanzen verhalten
wenn die wurzeln wirklich in die
verrottende paprika reinwachsen aber ich
denke im prinzip sollte das kein problem
sein man wird diese pflanzen auf jeden
fall groß ziehen und zitieren können das
dauert ja auch nicht mehr lange bis sie
ihre laubblätter ausbilden und man sie
dann sowieso in den eigenen topf
pflanzen würde also das funktioniert
schon mal ist aber ein bisschen eklig
weil die paprika wirklich ekelhaft am
vergangen ist beim zucker mais ist wie
erwartet natürlich nichts passiert das
hätte mich auch extrem vor rätsel
gestellt wenn da irgendwas gewachsen
wäre gekochte maiskörner die nicht am
kolben aus reifen konnten und dann auch
noch gezählt wurden keine chance machen
wir weiter wird dem knoblauch da hat
sich tatsächlich was getan auch wenn es
ziemlich ekelhaft ist also die wohl
pläne sind schon ziemlich an vergammeln
und ruhm stinken aber die hat ganz viele
wurzeln nach unten in das wasser
ausgebildet und ja leider tut sich hier
oben noch nicht so wirklich was das
heißt die sprosse wachsen dann noch
nicht raus ich denke wenn das so lange
dauert bis sich da irgendwas tut und
wenn es so viel einfacher ist die zehn
einfach in die erde zu stecken man sich
da nicht ist halbe wohnzimmer mit voll
stinken muss dann würde ich das auf
jeden fall einfach ganz normal machen
ich verlinke euch das video zum
knoblauch stecken da oben in der ecke
das ist wirklich viel viel einfacher als
mit diesem hack hier dann schauen wir
uns als nächstes mal andere wahl ich bin
gespannt ich habe da auch schon länger
nicht mehr rein geschaut also die ist
noch hier in diesem feuchten küchenkrepp
also so richtig was getan hat sich
nichts diese weiterhin offen also man
kann da rein gucken wie sieht ein
bisschen dämlich aus ist sehr dunkel
geworden aber kein walnuss spross zu
sehen machen wir weiter mit einem tollen
experiment nämlich dem lauch das hat auf
jeden fall gut geklappt seht ihr das da
ist schon ein ganzes stück raus
gewachsen
das ist also ein toller weg weil ich
meine ganz ehrlich das untere stück vom
lauf da schmeißt man ja sowieso weg und
wenn man da dann noch neue gemüse daraus
ziehen kann ist das doch eine supersache
das einzige was mich daran wirklich
genervt hat war dass es ekelhaft stinkt
wenn man nicht alle zwei tage konsequent
das wasser tauscht das wird auch ganz
schnell schleimig hier unten der rauch
hatte noch viel mehr wurzeln gebildet
und die sind dann irgendwann abgebrochen
oder so beim wasser wechseln und haben
ekelhaft gestunken also das war
teilweise ganz schön krass wenn man
regelmäßig das wasser tauscht dann ist
das eine ganz coole sache und man kann
sich auf der fensterbank das eigene
gemüse aus abfall ziehen voll kunden bei
der kamille ist es ja noch gar nichts
passiert ich habe dafür zwei erklärungen
optionen die eine wäre das in diesen
blüten einfach keine ausgereiften samen
drin sind hier dem tee enthalten sind
das heißt kamillentee enthält einfach
keine samen bei die blüten zu früh
geerntet wurden und die andere erklärung
ist dass unser t bisschen anders aus als
der in dem video
und das ist mit anderem t vielleicht
geklappt hätte wenn das jemand von euch
schon mal probiert hat dann könnte ja
mal berichten ob es funktioniert bei uns
jedenfalls ist nichts gewachsen bei der
melone ist auch noch nichts passiert was
mich ziemlich wundert weil ich diese
methode mit dem vor keimen in dem papier
crêpes bei allen möglichen gemüsen immer
wieder verwenden und dass da eigentlich
sehr gut funktioniert vielleicht haben
sie bisher einfach waren wir zu
ungeduldig aber nach drei wochen sollten
diese haben eigentlich raus kommen das
heißt die nach ein paar tagen hier in
den topf umgesetzt so wie das in dem
video glaube ich auch stand und jetzt
warten wir und warten sie haben die
sogar die heizung gestellt weil ja eher
warme temperaturen wollen unter die
heizung mich auf die heizung also
eigentlich hatten sie perfekte
voraussetzungen aber bisher ist nichts
passiert jetzt kommen wir zu den
erdbeeren da habe ich mich auf jeden
fall schon sehr darauf gefreut da war
ich auch schon sehr gespannt drauf da
hat sich einiges getan aber vielleicht
nicht unbedingt das was wir uns erhofft
haben die drei stücke sind schön egal ob
verschimmelt und erdbeerpflanzen sind
weit und breit nicht zu sehen also das
war leider nichts machen wir weiter mit
der karotte die hat man ja auch einfach
abgeschnitten und ins wasser gelegt das
heißt dass es wieder so eine art
resteverwertung da stand dass man die in
die erde um pflanzen soll wenn sich
wurzeln gebildet haben aber bei uns
haben sich überhaupt keine wurzeln
gebildet jetzt in den drei wochen was
sich gebildet hat ist ein kleines süßes
möhren blatt also ein bisschen was hat
sich getan aber ganz ehrlich wenn hacks
so lange auf sich warten lassen oder die
ergebnisse von hacks dann sind es
irgendwie auch nicht so coole hacks was
dagegen richtig die gut funktioniert hat
ist unsere tomaten experiment schaut
euch das mal an ich bin total begeistert
da sind super viele tolle pflanzen
rausgewachsen nur schade dass ich jetzt
nichts mit denen anfangen kann tut mir
leid aber
das hat richtig richtig gut geklappt
also ist es eine ganz tolle sache man
muss eben darauf achten dass man samen
feste sorten benutzt um das zu machen
weil die meisten tomaten die man im
laden kauft wie ich schon erzählt habe
übrigen sind das heißt macht das nicht
einfach mit ganz normalen supermarkt
tomaten sondern nur mit den kohl tomaten
die man weiter vermehren kann die man
manchmal auf dem wochenmarkt bekommt
oder bioladen dabei nachfragen dann
klappt es wunderbar also ziemlich cool
und faszinierend und unsere rose sieht
mittlerweile so aus sie hat ja noch so
eine kleine knospen dran an der hat sie
versucht noch eine blüte zu bilden aber
ganz ehrlich das hat überhaupt nicht
funktioniert
ich habe auch schon gesagt ich glaube
mit manchen blumen könnte das klappen
mit manchen nicht keine ahnung ich kenne
mich jetzt auch mit rosen überhaupt
nicht aus da sind sicher einige von euch
fitter auf dem gebiet ihr könnt ja mal
erzählen wie man das so macht wenn man
rosen stecklinge nehmen möchte das ist
auf jeden fall die hose gegangen so viel
zu diesen recruitingvideos also das muss
man immer auch ein bisschen hinterfragen
was man da zu sehen bekommt wenn du
einen richtigen garten anlegen möchte
ist und nicht nur auf der fensterbank
gärtnern willst und ich frage wie groß
der denn sein soll so dass er zu dir
deine erfahrungen und dem was du vorhast
mit deinem garten passt dann schau mal
da drüben vorbei da erkläre ich dir
nämlich wie du deine perfekte gar an
größe festlegen kann